krach um lieferungen und verträge die eu
will nicht hinnehmen dass der
pharmakonzern astrazeneca vereinbarte
impfstoffmengen kürzt krawalle
brandstiftung und ein zerstörtes
testzentrum in den niederlanden
eskaliert der protest gegen die korona
politik der regierung und ein haus für
12 millionen bücher die berliner
staatsbibliothek unter den linden ist
fertig saniert für das lesen und
forschen in einer zukunft jenseits von
corona
die nachrichten nicht erst heute mit
christian sievers und in allen und
willkommen bei uns in einer neuen woche
heute um 7 mit sport und christin voller
freude kund
immer neue berichte über lieferengpässe
beim impfstoff führen zu immer
drängenderen fragen und das ausgerechnet
beim einzigen lichtblick in einer
düsteren lage
deutschland hat viel zu wenig impfstoff
bei der zahl der geimpften sind wir
international alles andere als vorn mit
dabei die eu koordiniert die beschaffung
für die mitgliedsländer und sie ärgert
sich aktuell über die firma astrazeneca
die die zusagen nicht einhält
die rede ist von 60 prozent weniger
impfdosen in zahlen statt 80 millionen
sollen wohl nur noch 31 millionen bis
ende märz geliefert werden
und das obwohl laut eu ein dreistelliger
millionenbetrag floss damit astrazeneca
schon monate vor der zulassung auf
vorrat produzieren konnte die kommission
erwartet antworten auf viele fragen
stefan leifert aus brüssel
die hiobsbotschaften von den
impfstoffherstellern reißen nicht ab
nun ist es der britisch schwedische
hersteller astrazeneca der wohl nicht
liefern wird was vereinbart war
60 prozent weniger dosen fürs erste
quartal als zugesagt während nur noch 31
millionen impfdosen bis märz den ganzen
tag krisentelefonate zwischen den
spitzen von eu-kommission und
unternehmen
die europäische union hat die
entwicklung des impfstoffs und seine
produktion vorfinanziert jetzt möchten
wir ergebnisse sehen die eu will wissen
welche dosen von astrazeneca bis heute
wo produziert wurden und an wen sie
geliefert wurden am freitag wird
astrazeneca wahrscheinlich die zulassung
für die eu erhalten doch noch immer ist
unklar warum das unternehmen die eu
nicht wie geplant beliefern kann andere
länder wie großbritannien aber offenbar
schon
ich finde das ist ganz einfach der
impfstoff muss aus großbritannien auf
den kontinent gebracht werden und wenn
astrazeneca weil das nicht macht
hat das gravierende konsequenzen nicht
nur rechtlicher art sondern was die
langfristige zusammenarbeit angeht
der astra zeneca chef sprach heute beim
virtuellen davoser weltwirtschaftsforum
eine antwort blieb er schuldig wir
sollten nicht vergessen dass das was wir
hier gemeinsam tun in der weltgeschichte
so noch nie gemacht wurde innerhalb
eines jahres einen impfstoff zu
entwickeln
sogar mehrere in diesem fall und davon
dann mehrere milliarden dosen
produzieren obwohl der heute größte
hersteller der welt gerade einmal
kapazität für eine milliarde dosen hat
das ist ein gewaltiges unterfangen über
zwei milliarden dosen hat allein die eu
bei sieben herstellern bestellt so
gewaltig dass unterfangen so schleppend
der staat und es bleibt der verdacht
dass andere länder da bevorzugt werden
und eben gerade nicht mit solchen
überraschenden verzögerungen kämpfen
müssen
anne gellinek in brüssel genannt anna
hat denn die eu selbst da gut genug
verhandelt die eu kommission wehrt sich
und verteidigt die eigene impfstoff
strategie man habe von anfang an auf
viele hersteller auf verschiedene
hersteller gesetzt man habe dafür
gesorgt dass alle mitgliedstaaten
bezahlbaren impfstoff bekommen und man
habe haftungsbedingungen erreicht die
besser sein als zum beispiel die in den
usa trotzdem kann man in der rückschau
sagen dass die kommission bei zwei
fragen offenbar doch falsch gelegen hat
das eine ist die frage der
produktionskapazitäten
hier hat man womöglich zu blauäugig den
firmen geglaubt dass sie eben die
bestellten mengen auch liefern könnten
und das zweite ist die frage des preises
denn hier bei astrazeneca liegt jetzt
der verdacht nahe dass die dass ein
anderes land die mengen die für die eu
produziert und im übrigen auch vor
bezahlt waren der eu zu einem
vertragswidrig höheren preis
weggeschnappt hat angesichts dieser
unfassbar hohen kosten des shutdowns
überall in europa sollte eigentlich
alles recht sein was diesen shutdown
verkürzt und muss man dann nicht
spätestens jetzt quasi die koste es was
es wolle strategie fahren oder geht das
gar nicht
ich fürchte dafür ist es zu spät wir
sehen ja bei firmen wie bei montech oder
bei dem pharmariesen astrazeneca dass
selbst die es nicht schaffen die
bestellten dosen rechtzeitig zu
produzieren obwohl sie damit ja sehr
sehr viel geld verdienen würden es ist
eben so dass eine impfstoff fabrik nicht
so einfach aufzubauen ist das ist ein
technologisch sehr schwieriger prozess
der zu dem jetzt groß industriell
sozusagen für die ganze welt produzieren
muss und das dauert bleibt also die
hoffnung dass die anderen impfstoffe die
noch auf ihre zulassung warten dann auch
wirklich geliefert werden können anne
gellinek der brüssel
dankeschön zwei weitere nachrichten noch
von der impfstoffforschung ermutigende
von der biotech-firma moderner sie geht
davon aus dass ihr impfstoff auch gegen
die ansteckende 'ran varianten aus
großbritannien und südafrika schützt
moderner will aber eine zusätzliche
auffrischung dosis testen
ein rückschlag dagegen für den konzern
merck und die das französische pasteur
institut sie geben ihren gemeinsamen
impfstoffkandidaten auf erste tests
hätten eine zu geringe wirksamkeit gegen
das coroner virus ergeben
die zweite hoffnung im kampf gegen
korona neben dem impfstoff ist ein
medikament zu finden dass erfolge
verspricht das
bundesgesundheitsministerium hat
aufsehen erregt mit der nachricht man
habe 200.000 dosen von zwei
antikörpertherapien gekauft die in den
usa eingesetzt werden
aber ein europa bislang nicht zugelassen
sind volker dutschek hat mehr dazu
das sind bilder die keiner sehen will
menschen mit cupid 19 infektionen auf
der intensivstation
dass die mal überfüllt sind dass es die
sorge von medizinern und politikern
gleichermaßen
das gesundheitsministerium hat jetzt
antikörper medikamente eingekauft die
vor allem bei der früh bekämpfung helfen
sollen
bei dieser therapie art erhalten die
patienten einen cocktail aus künstlich
erzeugten corona abwehrstoffen die
antikörper sind alle gleich und docken
an das corona virus an
dadurch wird verhindert dass es in
weitere zellen eindringen kann
in dieser woche sollen die ersten 18
1000 dosen verteilt werden
experten streiten biochemiker vom
max-planck-institut sehen vorteile der
neuen therapie für ältere corona
patienten und risikogruppen dadurch dass
eine solche sollte das medikament das
noch keine volle zulassung erhalten hat
immer nur selektiv eingesetzt werden
kann und in dem fall so wie es heißt
auch nur an unikliniken halte das für
sinnvoll entsprechende patienten zu
finden für die es zu den kritikern
gehört die arzneimittelkommission der
deutschen ärzteschaft weil die
medikamente nicht in langen studien
geprüft sein könnte man nebenwirkungen
nicht ausschließen
die frage stellt sich natürlich der
haftung wenn solche schäden auftreten
bei einem nicht zugelassenen
arzneimitteln haftet nach meinem
eindruck der staat das heißt die
bundesrepublik deutschland und das ist
sicherlich eine frage die man auch mit
dem medizinrechtler noch erklären sollte
man muss eine sehr sorgfältige
aufklärung machen
noch sind viele fragen offen der streit
über die antikörper medikamente wird
sicher weiter gehen
neue medikamente also gegen korona da
stellen sich viele fragen
sie können ihre ihre einem renommierten
biotechnologen stellen und zwar um halb
acht bei zdf heute live über youtube
facebook oder über unsere zdf heute
besonders große sorgen machen die
mutationen des virus auch für
deutschland befürchten experten dass die
besonders ansteckende britische variante
die oberhand gewinnen könnte bis
einschließlich gestern meldet das
robert-koch-institut 51 bestätigte fälle
von b1 17
infizierte werden aus insgesamt acht
bundesländern gemeldet
einen großen ausbruch gab es in einer
berliner klinik henriette de maizière
es ist tag 3 das über das humboldt
klinikum im berliner stadtteil
reinickendorf grundsätzliche quarantäne
verhängt worden ist
allein hier wurde bisher bei 22 personen
die mutierte variante des corona virus
nachgewiesen
zwei weitere an einem anderen standort
des klinikums doch die hoffnung ist so
seien geschehen das was ich im humboldt
klinikum abspielt das ist eine
prinzipiell gute nachricht weil sie
bedeutet es ist nicht so dass vier
stadtweit überall hotspots sind und wir
gucken müssen das die ganze stadt jetzt
ein problem hat nein das was wir
nachweisen ist erfreulicherweise zur
zeit begrenzt allerdings gibt es
mittlerweile in berlin drei weitere
nachgewiesene fälle der so genannten
britischen variante zwei davon außerhalb
von kliniken virologen gehen davon aus
dass die mutante bis zu 35% ansteckender
sein könnte und so sieht die
bundesregierung trotz erster erfolge des
shutdowns grund zur sorge
wir haben jetzt eine ganze menge
indikatoren die hoffnungsvoll stimmen
und uns zeigen dass wir auf dem
richtigen weg sind und wir haben im
hintergrund die dunkle wolke einer sehr
ernsthaften gefahr nämlich der mutante
die dunkle wolke die mutante b 11 7 die
entwicklung in berlin stehen erst an
ihrem anfang und wir bleiben auch beim
thema corona zu hause schnell selbst
testen ob man infiziert ist auch das
könnte im kampf gegen die pandemie sehr
helfen und wird schon länger von einigen
experten gefordert jetzt will der
gesundheitsminister die voraussetzungen
dafür schaffen und eine verordnung
ändern damit die tests an privatleute
verkauft werden dürfen die hersteller
sagen solche einfach zu handhabenden
tests könnten in einigen wochen auf dem
markt sein
und das ist der aktuelle stand der
pandemie in deutschland allerdings sind
die zahlen montags ja in der regel etwas
niedriger weil am wochenende weniger
getestet und gemeldet wird
die gesundheitsämter meldeten dem
robert-koch-institut 6729 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden vor einer woche waren
es noch 412 mehr
die zahl der todesfälle in verbindung
mit dem virus stieg um 217 die korona
pandemie wird in den meisten ländern der
welt die soziale ungleichheit
verschärfen
davor warnt die hilfsorganisation oxfam
in einer studie
das vermögen von vielen reichen sei auch
in der krise noch gestiegen menschen in
armut seien dagegen dem virus stärker
ausgesetzt lebten unter bedingungen die
eine ansteckung wahrscheinlicher machen
und auch beim thema impfen haben sie
laut oxfam schlechtere chancen
über die hälfte der impfstoff vorräte
seien von wenigen reichen ländern
aufgekauft wurden verstörende szenen in
den niederlanden in etlichen städten
dort haben gegner der aktuellen corona
maßnahmen randaliert darunter auch
hooligans und neonazis unter anderem
wurde ein corona testzentrum in brand
gesteckt der ministerpräsident sagt das
ganze habe nichts mehr mit legitimen
protest zu tun
eine klinik
aufräumen am bahnhof von eindhoven am
tag danach zusammen gegen gewalt malt er
aufs pflaster
dieser aufruf kommt zu spät gestern
nachmittag gleich die innenstadt von
eindhoven einem schlachtfeld
demonstranten zünden autos und fahrräder
an verwüsten den bahnhof plündern
geschäfte stunden lang muss der
zugverkehr angehalten werden auf den
straßen setzt die polizei unterdessen
wasserwerfer und tränengas ein
die proteste hatten sich an der
nächtlichen ausgangssperre entzündet die
am samstag in kraft getreten war
der bürgermeister von eindhoven ist
entsetzt meine stadt weint und ich tue
es auch wenn ich mir angucke was hier
passiert ist dann ist das eine sehr
reale situation die man in den
niederlanden nicht erwartet
straßenschlachten auch in amsterdam und
anderen städten über 250 menschen werden
verhaftet
schon am samstagabend war nördlich von
amsterdam eine corona teststation
angezündet worden
die polizei spricht von einer mischung
aus corona leugnern rechtsradikalen und
fussball hooligans
die frage wird und man fragt sich was
diese leute antreibt das hat nichts mit
protest zu tun sondern nur mit
kriminalität und genau so werden wir das
auch behandeln zu lockern da noch über
homburger die menschen in eindhoven sind
geschockt und besorgt die polizei
befürchtet weitere ausschreitungen in
den nächsten tagen
[Applaus]
unser nächstes thema heute abend der
fall navalny die festnahme des kreml
kritikers und die großdemonstration am
wochenende die vorgänge in russland
waren heute thema bei den
eu-außenministern auf sanktionen gegen
moskau konnten sich die minister nicht
einigen
obwohl vor allem die baltischen staaten
strafmaßnahmen fordern jetzt sollen noch
ein gespräch mit dem kreml im februar
abgewartet werden navalny war vor einer
woche bei seiner rückkehr nach moskau
festgenommen worden und wurde zunächst
zu 30 tagen haft verurteilt
portugals konservativer präsident marcel
ospel oder schuster ist mit absoluter
mehrheit wiedergewählt worden
bei den präsidentschaftswahlen bekam der
amtsinhaber gut 61 prozent der stimmen
die wahlbeteiligung lag historisch
niedrig bei knapp 40 viele menschen
waren wohl wegen der dramatisch hohen
corona zahlenden portugal zu hause
geblieben und jetzt zweimal
bemerkenswertes zum thema klimawandel
deutschland gehört zu den am schwersten
betroffenen ländern der vergangenen 20
jahre beim klima risiko index der
umweltorganisation germanwatch liegt es
an acht zehnter stelle konkret wegen
fast 11.000 hitze toten in dem zeitraum
aber auch wegen wirtschaftlicher
folgeschäden durch den klimawandel in
deutschland und 3,5 milliarden euro pro
jahr
die größten probleme haben aktuell
entwicklungsländer wie mosambik oder
simbabwe vor allem um diese
hauptleidtragenden geht es heute und
morgen beim virtuellen klimagipfel in
amsterdam staats und regierungschefs
beraten wie sich die welt am besten an
die folgen der erderwärmung anpassen
kann
zum ersten mal mit dabei auch der neue
us klimabeauftragte john kerry jetzt zu
einem berliner comeback nach 15 jahren
renovierung und einer sehr lange sehr
bewegten geschichte davor die berliner
staatsbibliothek unter den linden ist
wieder offen
eines der bedeutendsten buch archive
weltweit mit schätzen wie etwa
originalpartituren von bach und
beethoven
gegründet 1661 und später dann
eingezogen in den riesigen bau unter den
linden
er wurde im zweiten weltkrieg schwer
beschädigt und zunächst nur notdürftig
renoviert
ab heute aber hat die bibliothek ihren
alten glanz zurück christhard läpple
berlin hat wieder eine internationale
top adresse die staatsbibliothek unter
den linden
willkommen im einst größten bildungs
tempel der welt nach 15 jahren
großbaustelle zeigt sich der kaiser
prachtbau im neuen glanz und mit
modernster technik kostenpunkt knapp
eine halbe milliarde euro rund ein
drittel teurer als geplant aber dies sei
gut investiertes geld in die zukunft
bibliotheken sind das kulturelle
gedächtnis einer nation und sowie das
kaiserreich sich hier ein zeichen als
bildungs und wissenschaftsregion hin
gebaut hat so haben wir heute natürlich
auch den anspruch zu zeigen dass das
große deutsche kulturelle gedächtnis
sich in büchern und in diesen
kostbarkeiten manifestiert die hier
aufbewahrt sind
die staatsbibliothek ist ein haus der
superlative größer als der reichstag
eine welt aus 25 millionen exponaten
büchern lexika noten und handschriften
alles was das herz begehrt darunter der
größte atlas der welt aus dem jahre 1664
gewicht 125 kilogramm bei der digitalen
der öffnung zitiert wolfgang schäuble
begeisterten schriftsteller borchers er
bekannte einmal er stelle sich das
paradies als eine bibliothek vor
ab heute hat das paradies wieder eine
berliner adresse und die heißt unter den
linden acht allerdings wegen corona
geschlossen
bis auf weiteres
das wird sich ändern bin ich ganz sicher
erst einmal den sport zum christin wir
gucken mal nach amerika in knapp zwei
wochen ist es wieder soweit eines der
populärsten sport ereignisse steht an
der 55 super bowl zum zehnten mal dabei
der wohl beste quarterback der
geschichte tomboy die diesmal echt
überraschend damit seinem neuen team aus
tampa tom brady und der superbowl zwei
alte bekannte
neu ist das team um ihn herum die tampa
bay buccaneers aus florida erst zu
saisonbeginn gekommen macht der
43-jährige ändert er rekordhalter aus
einer durchschnittlichen
footballmannschaft einen echten
titelanwärter drei touchdowns reichen
beim 31 26 erfolg gegen die favoriten
green bay packers das finale kann nun
kommen und das im eigenen stadion zum
ersten mal in der nfl geschichte
überhaupt genießt ein team heimrecht im
super bowl
gegner dort die kansas city chiefs die
titelverteidiger mit dem 18 jahre
jüngeren star-quarterback patrick mathys
nach sechs erfolgen mit den new england
patriots greift brady nun mit tampa bay
nach seinem siebten titel beim fußball
bundesliga verein hertha bsc wird pal
dardai neuer trainer mit einem vertrag
bis sommer 22 der ungar hatte die
berliner bereits vier jahre lang bis
mitte 2019 trainiert und aus england ist
zu hören dass laut medienberichten
thomas tuchel neuer teammanager des fc
chelsea werden soll
bestätigt ist das allerdings noch nicht
seit 2016 haben deutschlands handballer
keine medaille bei einem großereignis
gewonnen
am abend wollen sie sich nun gegen polen
von der wm in ägypten versöhnlich
verschicken
einmal müssen dafür die gelenke und
schultern der dhb auswahl noch
durchhalten nach dem verpassen der
ko-runde will man im letzten wm spiel
aber auch weitere erkenntnisse sammeln
denn bereits im märz geht es für das
team von bundestrainer kießler sondern
die so wichtige olympia quali gegen
polen ist dafür zum abschluss genau die
richtige herausforderung
wir werden unbekümmert spielen wollen
uns ärgern und ist das gefährliche daran
aber ich glaube wenn wir wieder unsere
stärken aufs spielfeld bringen
das sieht man auch die stärkere
mannschaft eingreifen wird wohl auch
wieder andreas wolf nachdem der em held
von 20 16 gegen brasilien aussortiert
wurde kehrt er wahrscheinlich gegen
polen ins deutsche tor zurück noch
einmal eine strähne gibt hinzufügen
danke christian schneefall straßenglätte
in der nacht und auch morgen
worauf sie sich da genau einstellen
sollten das erklärt gleich katja schäfer
ich empfehle ihnen das heute journal mit
der kollegin bettina schausten um 21 uhr
wir sehen uns sehr gerne morgen wieder
aber erst von uns allen ihnen einen
angenehmen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren da
kann so einen wolken paket doch richtig
unscheinbar aussehen wie dieses kleine
wolken paket östlich von schottland das
ist aber heute über die nordsee
herangezogen und jetzt aktuell kommt es
schon an der nordseeküste mit regen und
je mehr dieser regen ins binnenland
hineinzieht wird daraus schneeregen und
schnee und schon in dieser nacht können
im nordstau der mittelgebirge 10 bis 20
zentimeter neuschnee fallen
morgen sieht dieses kleine schnee die
weiter und erreicht auch bayern da
müssen sie sich nach wie vor auf
winterliche straßenverhältnisse
einstellen
heute nacht vor allen dingen im
südlichen niedersachsen und den
nordrhein westfalen am alpenrand und in
den mittelgebirgen
bei tiefsttemperaturen zwischen plus ein
und minus sieben grad morgen liegen die
höchstwerte meist um den gefrierpunkt
etwas milder wird es am rhein und hier
im nordwesten mit vier bis sechs grad
wenn das kleine schneetief morgen bayern
erreicht haben wird lockern die wolken
nordwesten schon wieder auf da der wind
aber durchweht müssen sie in bayern auch
mit schneeverwehungen rechnen und damit
das schneebruch auftritt dass nämlich
der feuchte schnee an den bäumen
festfriert und dann äste abbrechen lässt
winterlich geht's erstmal weiter
donnerstag und freitag wird das damals
von westen markant milder dann droht
tauwetter und hochwasser seien noch